i don't know what it is give me a darker
one yeah you have a darker one
like i'm dying or something i don't know
i don't have that but i do have a girl
i'll just get to her her question is she
or he just moved here to the states
having a hard time finding a job from
the philippines basically wants any
advice
uh for someone new to this country
basically well that that's so little
like what's her skill set
uh working right now as a barista at a
mom and pop shop but
doesn't like was an engineer back how
old is he okay is the engineer back home
you could just take the equivalent of
the engineering exam or whatever it is
maybe it might require a couple more
classes
or do like a refresher course and if
that's what you want to do then do that
how old is he 26. it's intimidating
though immigrant
person i think it's intimidating i can
only imagine moving from another country
but
i think coming from most parts of the
country to
a lot los angeles or new york you know
the two big big cities we have
i mean i remember landing here how old
were you 22.
i was 22 years old and i was like you
know there's a thing where like you want
to understand the
like the layout of the city so like i
knew like what hollywood was
and then i was i was like i guess i
should live there
and at first my friend my friend was
from la and he was like come out to
sherman oaks
and i was like i don't what what is that
and like you get on the freeway and then
you're like am i outside of la now
like you don't under you know i mean
like yeah geographically you spend a few
years
like learning how to navigate that's
true this city because it's so
spread out like in a way new york is
almost more comforting
because everything it's more like
compact and condensed
and you go these are the places but here
you're talking about our county is over
500 square miles and
you know to find like i remember you
know just finding figuring out like
like a neighborhood or two and a couple
spots you're like all right cool i got
it i got la i figured it out
but you just figured out like a
neighborhood because it can feel like so
much i mean i can't imagine
coming here from another country and
trying to like even from san diego
when i was raised in san diego and i
used to take these
improv classes gary austin's improv
classes in burbank i had never been to
la right and
they were at night so i remember driving
the 405 up from san diego
and as soon as i hit like um
what's that museum up there on the 405
uh big getty the getty museum right
and i remember one time i was listening
to frank black's song los angeles
on my shitty radio and i was like at its
cassette or whatever
and i'm going and i just remember this
overwhelming film
feeling of just like dread almost
because the whole thing felt so large
the city i don't know yeah
right and then getting on the 101 right
and you're just like oh the freeways
make you crazy yeah and then
yeah to really like when you really go
like what the [ __ ]
is when you start flying in and out of
lax and you
there's certain times on the approach
where you look out and you're like what
the [ __ ]
stands for the expansive i will say for
this guy
because you know i came here when i was
15. the first couple years living in
america and landing in los angeles was a
[ __ ] blur and he's
probably a little hell is he 26 27 26
yeah i mean you're a little you're a
little more mature and kind of developed
i remember like
do i remember just trying to like figure
out where to go and like
that strip the popular strip of melrose
i'd be like oh that's just where you go
i thought i mean like if someone came to
town you're like let me show you
something
also there was a show there was always
there was a show based on melrose right
yeah yeah so
people are familiar with the work this
is where the show was shot you know
and then like the next day they're like
what do you want to do today like let's
just go back to melrose yeah yeah
or like when friends have never been to
la and i'm like oh where are you staying
and they're saying all the way in the
west side i'm like oh i can't see you
oh yeah i don't see you like yeah you
chose the wrong
area you didn't consult with me earlier
i
it you know especially but pre-coveted
that's an hour and a half drive
to you i'm not going to see you i'm
sorry that shows you how much i
wanted to be with you for me to drive
from
where was i living hollywood to [ __ ]
long beach
every day every [ __ ] day that is 100
true because
people say that things are like
important to them but it's all about
how they act you know and like this is
why i don't [ __ ] buy
anyone's ever excuse for like if the if
you like someone
you know i mean when they're like i like
her but you know she lives in long beach
she's like then you don't like her you
know
yeah like you don't like her that much
you're right i didn't literally friend
that much they're like uh you know
and like dude if you're crazy if you're
into someone
you don't care if they're in [ __ ]
bangladesh like you're gonna you're
gonna
make it happen you know i would sit in
traffic for three hours at some times
yeah dude three hours when i started
dating christina i lived
in the valley and she lived in pasadena
wow that's still pretty a nice gap yeah
i mean that was
you know and also i don't know what it
is but the 210 to pasadena on like rush
hour is the worst
it's a night right now yeah and also
it's it feels like you know you're like
you learn an area
pasadena felt like just a whole new
different city honestly
pasadena is still it is another city but
i'm saying like it felt like a whole
other
world to learn how the [ __ ] do i get
around here
we go there just for breakfast burrito
we do really cookie boys lucky boy boy
lucky boy you know the best [ __ ] uh
breakfast burrito that i've had
in the south bays uh koreans make it
where it's called fannies
c so no it's avenue c redondo beach
redondo beach yeah
you know your friend alex the other day
when i wanted him to do me a favor was
to get me breakfast burritos